je viens d'un pays où les jasmins pousse
bien en fait qui connaît le jasmin dans
la salle lever les mains s'il vous plaît
non non c'est pas mon jasmin sort quand
je pense au jasmin je me souviens d'un
petit fleurs blanches avec 6 bettal et
un parfum tellement spécial dans ce
parfum là il y à tous mes souvenirs de
damas et de la syrie elle est toute
petite elle est une petite cette fleur
mais pour les syriennes
elle représente beaucoup dans leur vie
le jasmin elle est dans les mains de
tous les amoureux même notre café de
matin elle est toujours accompagnée avec
un peu du jasmin elle parfume les cafés
etc comme un signe de bon journée ça
suresnes où celle jasmin c'est les gens
la vie les rues
donc je crois que ses racines et sa
parfums doivent rester là-bas dans sa
terre quand j'étais arraché à mater j'ai
laissé le jasmin dans sa terre depuis
j'ai appris de vivre au gré devant un
vent qui rougit de ciel et la terre
1900 jour où vivre c'est vivre par
chance tu sais pas si tu vas vivre où tu
vas mourir quand on a dû partir mon père
nous a dit au moins à ma petite soeur et
à mon frère
vous pouvez prendre deux choses
important pour vous auquel vous prenez
donc j'ai pris des petits monts de mes
amis et quelques photos en quittant la
syrie en 2016 j'ai tout laissé et j'ai
tout perdu j'ai perdu mes amis les lieux
que j'aime mes habitudes tout ce prix
payer pour retrouver la sécurité et
d'ailleurs pendant le voyage
on était muet on était incapable de
parler je n'avais pas encore accepté que
ma vie était en train de changer dans
l'avion je ne voyais que l'immensité du
ciel
c'était tellement abstrait je
connaissais la destination mais ce
n'était pas suffisant
ça sera quoi demain la vie pour moi
donc maintenant je vais vous rencontrez
comment c'est commencer cette nouvelle
vie la première fois la première étape
où on imposer nos pieds c'était
l'aéroport de frankfort la police de
l'air ne comprenais rien nous étions en
règle nous avions devraient visant nous
avons été tous séparés mais ma petite
soeur ils ont cherché où nous allions et
comment et grâce à qui et ils ont
cherché aussi si nous disons tous la
même chose ça ça a été ma première
impression d europe
c'était salle accueille s'était pas
normal quand nous avons débarqué à
toulouse
cette école il n'avait pas de soldats
pas de milices les gens aller vite mais
il n'avait pas de panique
c'était ça la sécurité mais je le savais
déjà
j'ai rien j'ai rien ici on allait avoir
quelle vie
la seul souvenir que j'ai de notre
arrivée à toulouse c'est la bruit de nos
valises qui roule sur le sol
et que c'était aussi vraiment mauvais
temps donc après nous sommes allés dans
la maison qui nous attendait on nous
avait préparé de pain mais m'ont pas en
moi et les plats elle est ronde
on ne met pas à côté de l'assiette on
s'en sert comme crier mais la baguette
on ne savait pas quoi en faire
c'est devenu dur tout de suite ma mère
elle a pleuré parce que elle a fait ce
qu'elle pouvait et moi et mon frère et
ma petite soeur on n'a pas mangé pendant
deux jours parce que rien ne ressemblait
à rien pour nous rien n'a été normal
donc le 15 mars 2016 j'ai planté mes
racines
à côté de toulouse j'ai passé cinq mois
avant d'entrer à l'école j'ai travaillé
beaucoup mon français
en fait je fais que ça je ne savais pas
où rencontrer des gens de mon âge
c'était vraiment dit si difficile
c'était pas en vie normale et puis j'ai
eu beaucoup de chance j'ai été accepté à
l'insa de toulouse 1-2 meilleures écoles
d'ingénieurs en france à la fin de la
guerre
je veux rentrer sur ma terre je veux
aider à reconstruire maciré donc cette
école est incroyable pour moi
puis d'abord j'ai fait les trajets
toujours en bus puis j'ai pu avoir un
chambre dans une résidence universitaire
c'était un chance mais un nouveau défi
vivre entre quatre murs et tout seul et
sur ses murs là les jasmins ne
s'accrochait pas
vous savez j'ai fait ce que je peux pour
vivre dans mon nouveau jardin mais les
autres ne s'intéressaient pas en moi
personne ne demande d'où je viens
comment je vivais avant pourquoi je suis
ici c'est difficile d'arriver dans un
nouveau jardin où les autres arbres
n'ont pas l'habitude dans mon jasmin
c'est vrai les études me prenait
beaucoup de temps beaucoup plus de temps
que les autres et étudiantes
mais je veux vivre aussi est ce que vous
voyez
oui alors je ne suis pas transparente
pourtant à l'école on ne remarque même
pas je vous assure j'ai fait ce que je
peux parler aux autres à la fin des
cours proposés un peu de café c'est
normal ça c'est pas difficile
je sais que dans mon peu dans mon pays
la cud est l'étrangère c'est normal mais
quand même la seule réponse que j'ai
envers à un autre fois vous imaginez
tous les jours allez au cours et vous
essayer au milieu des autres et rien ça
ne passe rien j'ai réussi à parler avec
mes amis du ciri mais pas avec mes
voisins en amphi en novembre 2016 c'est
devenu trop dur j'étais découragé j'ai
voulu rentrer chez moi et j'ai écouté
mes parents se disait on a fait tout ça
pour ça j'étais triste après un jour et
comment je connais et j'ai compris que
les autres et la situation ne changerait
pas et que la seule solution que je
change mon regarde surtout ça et je me
suis remise en marche
en ce moment quand je marche dans les
rues de toulouse
je reconnais l'odeur du jasmin je
connais bien que c'est pas le mien mais
je m'y accroche quand même j'ai 20 ans
je rêve de vivre la vie d'un jeune fille
comme toutes les autres étudiantes
est ce que vous savez ce que j'aime
j'aime le fitness j'aime dessiner
j'aime rigoler avec mes copines je veux
chanter je veux danser comme j'étais en
syrie
enfants de tous
pays en défaut main meurtrie mais
l'amour et puis
mais la vie
enfin de tous
tout e vous avez dans le coeur
c'est dans vos mains que demain leurs
terres
et pour sortir de la nuit
et nos espoirs de revoir la lumière
et dans vos
qui s'éveille à la vie
séchez vos larmes jetez vos armes fait
du monde
un paradis
enfin le tout
on les voit mal qui se
et
la vie